so the way I divide my time between
open-source development and growing my
own business is to combine those two
things so when I work on open source
development it's usually for myself I
work on features that I need for my
business I work on bug fixes that I need
for my business and I think the
wonderful thing about open source is
that if we all do that if we all just
work on our own problems and our own
desired features and then share them
with each other we'll get something
amazing that's exactly what rails is in
fact I think things start to go wrong
once that's no longer true once you
start working on features for other
people and designing for other people
and imagining what they might need and
imagining how they might use it that's
hard it's really hard to design for
other people like that it's so much
easier to design for yourself and when
you design for yourself you know exactly
when it's right
you know when the grip is just perfect
you know when the sharpness of the blade
is just right not too sharp not too dull
just there you can't get to that point
of excellence by approximation it's very
very hard to just try to envision what
the good thing is if you can't feel it
on your own body so for me there's no
conflict I work on open source stuff
when I need it and when I need it it
makes perfect sense to do it and it's
sort of a byproduct of that then I
didn't get to share it I'm gonna be no
poorer because I shared this open source
software that I developed anyway I
needed it already so if I give it away
after it's already done
what am I losing exactly nothing I'm
gaining a ton of stuff though I'm
gaining that I'm putting this into a
wonderful beautiful Commons and
everybody else is doing the same thing
and all the actors walk away from that
richer
I'm no open source sealant I don't need
everything in the world to be open
source
I don't need old software products to be
open-source in fact I preferred that
there are not I prefer to pay for things
what I do find is that there's a lot of
stuff a lot of infrastructure code in
particular about our applications that
are not part of making our applications
special the base camp the high-rise the
campfire the backpack all the
applications we have they could be built
on something else in Ruby on Rails to be
honest that means that Ruby on Rails is
probably not the secret sauce it is not
what defines these applications thus if
I give it away I'm not giving something
up now if we open source Basecamp and
sit right you can just download it
running on your machine contribute
something back to us well what are we
selling if you give it away for free
they're not also we're gonna pay for it
at least not very many are